won't look it won't listen to me no
matter how many times I try won't listen
to me that's interesting your old clip
to test three work yet if this is live
well now maybe it's still branded as
test 2 then its finances probably yet
let's see
no this is a 1-minute video
simulation is live now there it is test
three cool all right now we're gonna
check check check just chose live now
there is test three okay cool
now what's the resolution on this video
can I turn this up to 1080p a ten good
and if I go here and the kachou and we
look all cool
[Music]
it's a funny feedback loop honestly it's
a very funny video PR the TLDR version
is that happy because that's that's all
they need to know really it looks like
it's working to just YouTube what I'm
gonna do is I'm just gonna keep I'm just
gonna keep this camera rolling as a test
and just keep talking but I'll be
further away I might make myself a
little something to snack on doo doo doo
doo doo doo doo doo doo I just want to
make sure that it's actually gonna keep
streaming because
like tomorrow it will be great if if
that will actually work
how many people do you think would watch
like like imagine if like sheesh in pink
or like Donald Trump or you know I'm
musk or some [ __ ] imagine if they were
like there's a live-streaming themselves
in the kitchen making something right
right it is because is them doing
something normal
yes yeah we love that do you want me to
make some smoothie tonight we're doing
me to wait till tomorrow I'd be down for
some tonight stuff but we also have make
it before we go but are we gonna eat
with some your grandma or Angela at all
either right we're not going with either
right correct so then let's um make in
the morning before we go
no I'll publish ways home way especially
because I'm already eating this and we
still have a little bit of this yeah
yeah we're still streaming because we
have to yeah well we have to know if
it's gonna work past one minute like
we've only done one minute test we have
to let it stream for like 20 minutes
tomorrow I'll probably go to dam
Stephanie's coming in the morning that's
right I was trying to think of a fight
huh do you want to there's probably no
one watching yeah if you want to here
throw this on no never mind this isn't
oh wait
let's see if there is anyone on
- there's a
good it still looks its high quality
stream still good yeah no one's watching
but you can say hi it's probably us it's
on yeah so basically where I would turn
this line man the volume is down now
because you don't want the volume yeah
how did your back into the mic so if I
see this one watching now go to two then
I can assume that I'm being watched
I think so yeah
say something yeah now this out there
someone watching Hey okay wait so people
watching oh we got three people watching
yo well we just well oh yeah cuz they
can talk in the chat you guys can talk
in the chat too Orion did you write this
the I wrote okay alright well listen
through you watching Alan it just went
down to two I don't think this is uh my
entry into being with eyeballs strangers
so whoever is here right now with me I
wanted to say hello I want to say hello
because right now we're on because
Alan's doing a test he's doing a data
test but since since
people are tuning into this I wanted to
playfully interact because I Ori is my
name and a new collaborator on the show
simulation and
I want to put my feet three watching
Allen three watching it basically up to
watching I was so I gave such an excited
response to the new guy but then he just
left unless it was unless there's the
old guy well listen if you'd like to say
something in the chat here even just a
Hello you might just make my hour you
know what I'm saying I wanted to be nice
to watch I want to be
if you want to eat me then click on me
but they just set in the jet you see it
yeah hey if you want to eat me then
click on me hey thanks for being a
returning viewer to our channel we
really appreciate you a lot things that
ever before
no that's their name and then that's
what they said the smiley face no way oh
my god we also really appreciate your
channel because their channel showcases
extreme animal aggression and violence
no way like slaughtering animals and
stuff yeah holy [ __ ] yeah Michael Vick
in the house oh I see what you mean like
documentary style like documenting that
not creating that well listen if you
want to eat me then click on me I want
to thank you for entering your smiley
face because now I actually feel like
someone's here with me and it feels
really good for some reason you know
it's so hard to feel it's so hard to
feel confident these days a lot being
live in front of a camera you know what
I'm saying then again I am new at this
so why don't I say something why don't I
throw in a smiley face here and
you got a visit from Alan you know if
you want to eat me then click on me you
got Alan to come by and say hello
oh the cube ninja just entered a smiley
face he entered a smiley face with teeth
bro yo the cube ninja what's up thanks
for the so good to have you here
that's what's so good to have Alan's
like a [ __ ]
Horry I'm back for that second viewer
smiley face I was like worried I
averaged 200 viewers every time I go
live so 50/50 cube ninja thanks for
tuning in
appreciate it cube ninja I want you to
know that year
oh the cube name just said I really have
to change this name Alan wants to know
why you say this the cube ninja
why do you really have to change this
name it's kind of a it's kind of a cool
name the Cuba they keep maybe he's
really good at doing number cubes
whatever you Rubik's cubes
we are sitting here eager to hear why
you really have to change this name this
is been streaming for this long that's
it good yeah I'm glad that another soul
is on the other side of this live stream
right now what
okay but now you can well look the Cuban
engines said because I think you're
asking some questions about it was you
can refuse to answer okay interesting
[Laughter]
I'm down let's ask you ninja holding
space stuff oh you wanna hold space with
the Cuban Joe why what's alive for you
about this so can feel special while not
being special we are holding space the
cube ninja I want you to know that to me
you are special because one example is
you made me feel better I'm new to this
show and sticky-up smiley face and ah
Alan's doing a little dance from hearing
your responses I wonder if the cube
ninja is a man or a woman
hmm Alan thinks a vast majority of the
people that watch YouTube I'm man like a
very male-dominated platform whereas
like Pinterest is a very female
dominated platform they said they don't
know they said they don't know Oh hmm
hey cube ninja hey where are you coming
from right now
I'm watching the child watching the
chair
hmm there's someone other than cube
ninja here he's in Germany awesome that
is awesome yeah that is awesome because
me and Alan are inspired to impact
globally so I feel very happy mm-hmm hey
cube ninja do you what are your thoughts
about source ooh that's gonna be an
interesting one
I don't know man it's not a one-word
answer maybe it is
about what she asked about horse Alan
why don't you explain what that means
could you write that down oh okay you
did three watching that means maybe us
cube ninja and another soul is present
right now and I just want to acknowledge
that namaste
it feels great I mean Alan's famous he
averages fifty live stream viewers but
I'm not what source the universe the
universe yes I love it
what's a great comment yeah let us know
your thoughts about source the universe
what created the universe what is the
purpose of all of this what are your
thoughts about that in your role in it
nice
sorry I really don't know what you want
but I think my answer mostly is I don't
care
nihilism nihilism every time you ask
about source or talk about source I am
imagining people like responding like
this well because it doesn't feel cool
to talk about weight yeah the antidote
to nihilism is meaning cube ninja so
what brings you the most meaning you
heard it from the man himself the cube
ninja no I think about it but in the end
I feel like it's an answer
meaning he or she asks I think we're
just watching their stream of thinking
right now
yes meaning capital M
what brings you meaning yeah dude that'd
be fun don't know the cube ninja doesn't
know what brings them meaning alright so
now we're holding space alright so now
we're holding space alright we're being
present with the cube ninja and we are
we're curious about the cube ninja in
the moment I'm not into having a thing
that gives me meaning nothing wrong with
that
maybe that's what means something to you
freedom or so yep
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's a good one what does freedom mean
to you hmm what does freedom mean I mean
that's the thing of religion what does
freedom mean to you the cube ninja me
and Alan are eager to hear and for the
other person watching the cube ninja
said I mean that's the thing of religion
giving you a false meaning for life you
know I used to be very into that way of
thinking I used to read reddit slash are
slash atheism every day for a year all
right this was in 2010-2011 ish all
right I identified as an atheist I
wasn't just an atheist it was it
nourished me to talk about being an
atheist and so and and so I can relate I
can relate
which are Dawkins and Christopher
Hitchens and Sam Harris and all these
mofos you know these brilliant minds
the cube ninja isn't even saying that
necessarily they're just saying like
yeah I don't really got nothing to say
about nothing nihilism nihilism
but me and Allen are here to freedom is
that one thing a lot of people think
they have opinion views about it but in
the end everybody just uses the word for
something positive for themselves
[Music]
thank you for a Alan we got for watching
Alan's like aurilla I don't Alan invites
anyone who would like to comment where
you're from who is currently watching
this live stream so freedom is that one
thing a lot of people think they have
opinion views about it but in the end
everybody just uses the word for
something positive for themselves yes a
very rational perspective a very
rational perspective interestingly when
I read that rational perspective when I
take it in when I look at it when my
heart opens to it when my consciousness
opens to it I feel a little down I feel
a little heavier I feel like I'm taking
on a perspective that is true but it's
only one true perspective and o-5
watching alright I'll stop bugging you
Alan all right all right
viewers my name is Horry and I am new to
collaborating with Alan on this show and
it's really juicy for me to witness your
presence here with me in the middle of
the night at least in California and I
invite you to say anything you want on
this chat if you'd like but for now I'm
having a little dialogue with the cube
ninja
well well I'm being supported by a
veteran in the game
Alan sake on to the dude interviewed
Jordan Peterson in front of how many
people 600
so five people
what should I address next what would
you like me to speak on
for people dun-dun-dun I don't want to
lose you guys there's like this this
like a high this is like a high you get
to to feeling like you're being watched
and received and appreciated and most of
all supported like I want to feel like
I'm brightening something or like I'm
like provide like meeting a need or like
healing something or like you know what
I'm saying because they I have that in
me that capability and and so so I'm
here if that if that wants to if that
wants to happen but I need some more
interaction maybe otherwise I feel less
connected to who I'm sharing time with I
feel less in touch with who I'm sharing
space with talk about how falling
numbers feel way more negative than
positive feeling of rising numbers and
how awkward it is to speak without
people answering that's what I was just
talking about it was great but you know
all right let me think let me think so
and then we also had someone a pig finit
pig fin it like infinite but with pig
said hello I'm here to interact smiley
face and then they cube ninja City a
nice hey good night
what's up guys we are so happy you're
here with us this basically made mine
Alan's night I mean Alan has a backlog
of like 24 interviews to edit and a
hundred facebook notifications but he
doesn't like looking at this stuff
anyway he prefers to play with the
present moment and pig finit in the cube
dinger hmm we really couldn't be happier
to be with you right now
we asked pig phonate a question now okay
um I do want to just to finish
acknowledging the cube ninja fur okay
his or her latest my by the way if I
take guess the cube ninja if you're a
woman or a man I would say a woman I'm
65 percent sure about that all right oh
I'm a fan of the channel I really enjoy
the interview you do Alan oh I agree
oh thank you Peter thank you so much
that's so kind of you to say I'm gonna
embrace Allen for you this is you this
is this isn't me Alan this is a pig fin
it it feels good I'm a man actually Alan
doesn't care good yeah I mean hey hey
fin it we I have a question I would love
to learn more about you who are you and
what do you care about
it's interesting that that that this
isn't that it's kind of slow the way
this is unfolding despite everyone being
here you know like the communication
takes a second well it's a hard question
it is a hard question five watching now
hello and welcome to the new person
me and Alan our Bobo Momo what are they
doing Pig Finn it the cube ninja you're
welcome to answer but hey Bobo Momo I
just want to say thank you so much for
your continued support of watching our
channel and making comments I've seen
you in the comments several times I
greatly appreciate you a lot thank you
and also let us know where you're from
and what you're passionate about we love
engaging with the dude or woman's
picture is an American flag so I think
they'd I know where they're from yeah
yeah we do want to hear from you I'm a
young adult who enjoys technology and
don't read it out loud so oh it's
alright
Pig Finn it said well I'm a young adult
who enjoys technology and delving into
topics like the universe and new ways of
creating things Oh sounds like a
simulation viewer mmm-hmm such as AI and
virtual reality interesting so big Finn
it so while you are delve into these
topics like the universe and these new
ways of creating things like AI and VR
where specifically does it feel like you
want to create where do you want to
contribute value as you learn about
those things how what do you want to
build
Alan's getting into his like Tony
Robbins policies row yeah there's a
Superfund engaging with people that was
so fun yeah like we should do this more
often yeah for real because we should
cherish these moments because in a
couple years what happens is when the
channel grows and you try this the
comments are like boo boo boo boo boo
boo boo boo boo boo boo boo boo boo and
they goes so fast I can't read them and
answer them right big finit said I think
I'd like to create things that help
people understand themselves on a deep
level Oh sounds timely Big Finish sounds
like exactly what the world the new
world is moving toward pick finit have
you watched the episode with joyous
heart where he talks about I am
self-actualization technology because
that specifically is about helping
people find their North Star and also
endeavor towards it and gamifying that
process and so I'm just wondering if you
watch on that one just dropped recently
you know what's interesting though when
I read Pig Finn instinct he or she said
people understand themselves on a deep
level which sounds a slightly different
than the purpose thing mmm the North
Star okay well understand themselves
sounds like going inward and inquiring
and there's like this dichotomy like
self-realization and self-actualization
okay self-realization being like Who am
I like getting a sense of that
BOGO Momo said I'm from Ukraine practice
my English here alongside with trying to
figure out what's going on in the US
taping it might have watched that other
video title but I don't know Forge yes
Pikmin it may have watched joyous heart
and then Pig Finn it also we would love
to learn from you about what you would
like to you cuz you said you think you'd
like to create things that help people
understand themselves on a deep level so
like what would be a good thing that
you'd think about creating to help
people understand themselves on that
deep level and Bobo that's cool that
you're from Ukraine hey Siva gavazzi
paru skiathos ago via paru escape
I'm whoosh spoke about some like
Borowski and if if he if he can speak
Russian I yeah and also it's funny that
you thought he was from the US but he's
so so I would say wire bubble Momo why
are you interested in what's going on in
figuring out what's going on in the US
okay cool and then to Pig Finn it who
mentioned that that pig Finn it said
that they should check it out this
interview that you shared Alan I would
like to I would like to
say that you might enjoy it I was
present when it happened
in joyous is a really really bright soul
really good guy and really brilliant as
well and he has a fascinating story and
I think the interview was captivating
I'm real interested in conversational AI
that reflects people so I think that
could be a good medium
I think of smarter child from AI em and
like BOTS like that which was the
original conversationally I I love her
it's one of my favorite movies also if
you're interesting conversational AI
that reflects people another good
company is Soul machines which is based
out of New Zealand
[Music]
Bobo Momo answered and talked in a
language that I don't know Russian pig
fin it has seen her or never seen her
but heard of Sol machines and really
like the robots from Hanson robotics
yeah me too I really like them as well
we just turn this mic on make sure I can
hear myself okay I can great alright
okay you had on the show yeah so that's
a good point because Hanson robotics is
crazy awesome and I think they are doing
things a little bit slow like they're
moving fast but they're also doing
things with I think a good amount of
emotional intelligence around the
importance of what they're doing and
taking it slow to make sure that they do
things right
gansan robotics and david and ben are
very interesting individuals and i think
they're thinking a lot about emotions
and behavior of these robots in the way
of the engagement these are robots is
gonna change our future which is great
it's good to see all the beautiful
people that are here right now in the
chat oh I didn't see that
and also Bobo Yakov aa risk of damage to
my above William Ian now Chilika go AIDS
my grandma taught me how to speak
Russian when I was a little kid and so
that's why I speak it that's a good
question though why on earth do you
speak Russian yeah question indeed I'm
really inspired by both Ben and David
yeah they are super cool beeps it was a
lot of fun having been on the show and
talking to him about decentralised
artificial general intelligence and the
way that he's kind of structuring things
around that I also feel like he's really
tapped into what the ultimate purpose of
creation is and I think he thinks about
it on the absolute macro level as well
as at the micro level I like it when
people's thinking spreads to those
levels
and I still have yet to have David on
the show but I've heard great things I'm
really looking forward to having him on
the show soon we needed to go do
interviews in Hong Kong that would be a
great place to do it it means that's
where his robotics is based out of them
now yeah
do you know Geno's good friends with
them too Hong Kong's right next to
Shenzhen
that's why Hardwick capital
yeah it's good - it's good to see peeps
tuned in you know guys we would love to
hear from you I want to ask you a
question what are your what did what are
your thoughts about the the ultimate
purpose of creation what is the point
oh I forgot you have an Armenian surname
that makes sense exactly Bobo exactly
yeah our median surname Alan sock you
know they do try and put a good
connotation around a I that's true and
it's also important to remember that a
lot of people just don't invest enough
time into understanding the nuance of a
I and when you get into the nuance
instead of just a binary thinking
modality of it's either good or bad
really the first thing that comes up is
who the [ __ ] is programming and with
what intentions
yeah
uh-huh mm and then if we can just get
people on board around the world that
hey like we need more ethicists and
philosophers that work with programmers
that are making a I and I were in a
better position if we promised and I use
it for arms race mentalities but instead
for maximizing flourish and eradicating
poverty maximizing degrees of freedom
for economic well-being I mean yeah the
list is [ __ ] endless the good ways to
use it but it requires us to coordinate
in its heart it's a big global
coordination problem around these things
it's funny it's interesting asking
people about what their thoughts are on
creation or what the purpose of the
human experience I'd never think we
should be careful about who works on the
AI and have a decentralized yeah and
what it learns from massive superboy
infinite is just showing up here today
before this heart aches and it's
bringing it bringing the pig fin it
energy here maybe I maybe you know what
I'm doing is I'm asking questions that I
want people to answer but not questions
that other people would want to answer
that's my problem I'm really trying to
ask like big universe questions
evolution of our understanding and
ability to manipulate the world that's
our goal it's a pretty good one Bobo I
like that one so like the point is we
should we should understand our
evolution and how we got here and then
also our ability to manipulate this
world so it's like we have to realize
that we're [ __ ] God and we have to
realize how to play God yeah but think
about how that might sound when you say
that it's like what are you talking
about you know but I'll say that we're
sober this is funny it's funny that
people keep saying like oh my god what
do you guys on we're like we're high on
life all the time we never do any sub
run Vargas's in the building or hot
Vargas's is the penalty
good luck with that he says of course he
says good luck with that building your
benevolent a human experiment Ron Vargas
is in the building
the preferred technical director of the
Bay Area we love you Ron yes what a
one-of-a-kind I was an interesting
comment there you had Ron at the end of
your call with Al and we use it you'll
slid it through
yes I'm high on life - yeah we know hi
I'm like with an asterisk good for sure
big today yeah that's true gosh
shout out to around Vegas for teaching
us how to use a multi-camera live stream
that's great that's a good though I like
I like Bobo's point like literally you
have godlike powers and now you have to
figure out how to prop how to play with
them check your phone no run save here
say what you want to say here Ron yeah
say what you want to say here if you can
just unless I think Ron sent me a video
or something I think is what he sent me
on look at the images I said okay all
right we'll look if I if I turn on my
NDI connection we can share with what's
on my computer with the viewers
oh my god Ron what did you do that has
new place oh that's your place Oh Oh
someone's been whoa
looks like someone [ __ ] with the
coasters
yeah
but it looks like people took stuff at
least but someone did [ __ ] with the
coasters mm oh and then Ron cleaned it
up
thank you Ron
I'm answered
Wow thanks Ron so for those that don't
know we we moved out of out of our older
studio in downtown SF and we and we what
is it is it available it's not it's not
reading yeah I input how do I let me see
if I can showcase one moment everyone I
want to try and get out of the NDI
connection
I wonder why the NDI connection isn't
isn't isn't working should show up
immediately
okay I'm gonna troubleshoot this MDI
connection later but um thank you Ron I
just want to say thank you yes yeah
actually I also just want to mention
that like it is ridiculous that that I
left the coasters that should have been
something that I took and recycled
somewhere else and nobody wants to take
simulation coasters but it does look
like at least people took the chairs
someone took the glass desk which is
good
someone took those tables which is great
it's not good that that um that the
people did that with the coasters but
now Ron it looks great there's only the
mattress left and also the the hmm the
dresser with the books on it thanks for
doing that wrong that looks that looks a
lot better I really appreciate that Ron
thank you go to the YouTube again yeah
sorry thank you Ron I just want to say
thank you for doing that
right you should the trash guys were
going to drive away I had to stop them
thank you Ron
bronzor Rockstar that's really
appreciate it it's a big time
I don't know but I'm glad I'm just glad
that I'm glad that it's all at all it
all worked out with being able to have
that space on Market Street
Ron basically you know put together the
live streaming pieces and then got me
equipped with the equipment and then and
got me rolling hard core so I'm and then
he's even kind enough to help make sure
that the place looks nice afterward Ron
said I'm glad it's over glad it's over
[Laughter]
I'm done waking up next to you he said
something really interesting recently
here move a little this way so you can
be in the shot but he said something
really interesting recently which was he
like woke up one morning and he walked
down there and he said he just looked he
just looked over at me and said uh good
morning
and then I think it was the first time
he said good morning like ever and he
was like don't get used to that [ __ ]
Bobo said humankind is constantly
evolving in its ability to understand
the nature and through this knowledge
a.k signs we can develop our
technologies our manipulation techniques
it's true
that's right
looks good sounds good going to bed have
fun Ron thank you so much thank you so
grateful for him such a major character
in my development technologically
interviewing knowledge Lee all of those
fields just haha thanks Ron
nice Pig Finn it's talking to Bobo now
hey that's what we're that's what we
really want yeah yeah yeah we want to
connect future couples
simulation your one-stop-shop for
connecting intellectuals and finally
with the help of the internet we can
finally start to properly study not just
physical matter but also human culture
and human consciousness damn Bobo's on
fire keyword properly study hmm you know
with the internet we can more properly
study human consciousness that's
interesting I hope so
Aussie Aussie Aussie Aussie oi oi oi a a
new person that's why I said that
this is YC dude Allen
Aussie I'm noticing that Allen and
people viewing I'm noticing that
live-streaming like this is like it's an
art and that and that your energy can be
manipulated by the equation of all of it
and all the people watching and how they
feel and what they think and the because
I feel my my life energy fluctuating hmm
and so it's like this based on what
though fluctuating based on what that's
it that's a good question the story in
my what Dumas hold on hey this is YC
what's up thank you for tuning in I
thought you had previously maybe seen
our content what we host on our Channel
is a show that interview some of the
greatest minds alive this is scientists
entrepreneurs spiritual leaders artists
we have long-form energy interviews with
them we also have short clips that we
circulate off from those interviews we
try and engage and inspire people in
building the future and manifesting
their dreams into the world so that's
what our channel is about I host the
show
orys another producer of the show and so
that's that's it so just so you have a
heads up I I would recommend when you go
subscribe it helps us a lot subscribe
that would be helpful also go to some of
the videos in the in the channel and go
and watch some of the ones that piqued
your interest
there's we're very multidisciplinary
there's tons of different interviews so
find one that piques your interest and
watch it and then see how see what it
makes you feel and how it makes you feel
and how maybe gets you inspired and then
go and talk to more people about that
style
about what was shared in that episode
you know so that's kind of what our you
know what our ethos is we have a lot
more things in the pipeline but that's
just a little taste of it for now Pig
finit I've done a bit of live stream
before I get that feeling it's a very
special feeling yeah this is as you do
you do you pay him or did he volunteer I
think he's talking about you right
so simulation has had one big a
particularly first started to show
financially and then we bottle the
equipment and then we've every single
month since then we've just been
month-to-month getting by and so nobody
gets paid on the show we just cover our
expenses every month so every month when
we were with Ron before it was just we
were paying for rent we were buying food
that kind of stuff it's the same thing
now with Laurie we're just paying rent
we're buying food we're not paying we're
not getting paid for anything we're just
building things that transcend us that
and other people and also Allen is
helping me with like food gas and rent
and also he's helping my gifts land and
be witnessed by more people you guys may
not know but I I've been interviewed on
the show twice and the thing I do is
what's called hold space you can check
out my website WWE Hall ding space com
Oh are I holding space comm and so these
are some of the exciting ways that
simulation helps support me so thanks
down mm-hmm yeah and Ori coming on board
is massive for our own spiritual
evolution not only my my own but also
our audiences and our guests that come
on the show we're now holding space with
our guests after the show for their own
conscious evolution it's been a lot of
fun you guys will see more of that
content coming out soon
you know it's good seeing uh dude yeah
this is super injured like the thing I
said about the energy
yeah and pig finit mentioned it yes
thank you pigs in it thanks for the
relating it is it is now I'm curious
like what's possible and if we can get
really skillful at this you know because
we already are becoming that when we're
sitting with people in person um in this
particular scenario I feel like I have
stuff to learn about managing my energy
and you know like the other night I all
my chakra is opened and like since then
I felt like really like spacious and but
now here doing this I feel like I feel
really sensitive like on a really real
level to being with you guys and and
like I feel like I feel like I'm being
like - like my Bloods being sucked or
something and like I wonder if I could
wonder if there's a way I could create
like a more nourishing container that's
like
like
I wonder if we could all become more
conscious of our energy and how we're
wielding it or using it or overlooking
it you know that fundamental energy of
perception and what it's being put onto
and wished and in order to understand
nature you need to manipulate experiment
I don't know man
everything that Oreo is just saying is
little get to vote was common in a
moment one moment so if you do something
like you take what you're feeling right
now in this live-streaming scenario and
you try and understand it more deeply
you maybe take into account how you're
feeling how other people are feeling as
they're watching what it means to have a
certain amount of viewers what it means
to be talking to them in the chat how to
optimize these things how can you make
the container feel like people can
express themselves fully in the chat can
you ask Pacific questions to engage
people more that'll get them more
excited to potentially share this
content with other people can you make
it so that someone literally can
consciously evolve in the chat instead
of in person yes yes
like if I'm a people I would love to
turn the focus to how can we make this
group right now right here flower
experientially so like how can we begin
to feel better and better as a group
being intentional about every move we
make every thought we have and every
word we share
and
I figured I had to look up Coles and
Woolworths which are it looks like two
of the biggest shopping grocery
supermarket chains in Australia it's
actually interesting to know that that
that's like another question that
policies well when when you say that
this is VC my sieve is YC y see my
reaction my emotional or kind of
reaction is like are you on my team are
we on the same team are we on a team
whoa do you believe in God Alan that's
the trigger word man gonna drop the G
word man
do you know let's just feet let's just
be it let's experience it together even
better do you feel God every moment of
life God within you God around you God
is creation do you feel that but there's
six other people who might be alright
let's let's let's all let's have a
little bit of fun here
this is gonna turn me into a hardened
like veteran when we do bigger live
streams it's gonna make me like - ah and
I'm gonna know what to say and where to
look and what to not acknowledge okay I
love it
Alan's like Horry I have er egde 50
viewers a live stream he keeps saying
that it's good you're getting me ready
yo if we actually want to get some Z's
tonight we got a crash okay yeah we got
a crash if it's uh we have six diehards
watching us not be smooth or pretty six
diehards six die hard energy this is a
really good training this is really good
practice Alan
I don't know doing shop Cole's or
Woolworths yo that's that's it we got a
rap that's true yeah all right thanks
everyone we appreciate you tuning into
this live stream test slash just cop
engagement with the different viewers
it's been a lot of fun it's also been
fun watching or you engage with everyone
so thanks for engaging with him for
those that are gonna watch this later
let us know your thoughts in the
comments below on some of the
conversations we had throughout and also
would love to have your support in
continuing to build this you find all
our links in the bar below for
supporting us with the other people in
your communities that you believe in as
well and gonna build the future everyone
manifest through dreams into the world
they love you very much thanks for
tuning in it was great talking to you
I'll try to stop by again in the future
thanks big Finn it thanks Pig Finn it
same thing yeah I think it was really
great sauce drew yeah thank you so much
for your kindness yeah yeah having you
awesome learning more about you as well
this is why you what are you guys gonna
do in bed you know wow wow wow yeah yeah
hopefully catch some good Z's hopefully
get some really good lucid dreams and
regenerating sleep mm-hmm but you know
you got to be you got to be as weird as
possible too I'm joking go build the
future around manifest those dreams
that's where all you love it very much
thanks for tuning in we'll see you soon